Vincent is with us in Pensacola hi
Vincent how are you doing okay doesn't
ask you how you're doing cause we've
already actually that some things are
like things are predictable how can I
help just start listening to your show
wish I would have 10 years again I
probably would he be in this mess but
currently going through a breakup and we
purchased the house together but I'm not
on the note due to a business cause
bankruptcy or eight years ago I paid
half down paid half of the monthly note
maybe share the tax refund each year
just kind of want to know what my legal
rights are to the property a breakup are
you getting a divorce no sir
so you were living that we're never
married you're living together okay yes
sir um I guess you'd have to seek an
attorney's advice how much equity is
there in the property about 150 Wow
pretty substantial okay and I I'm
assuming she wants to stay in the
property yes sir she wants to refi a bit
full qualifier nuts and she knows she
says she wants to give you a partial
payment of like 75% and then make
payment on the pallets with her current
credit card debt and screaming I'm just
I don't know maybe you can give me some
buy songs
yeah last thing I wanted to be getting
payments from an old girlfriend I know I
don't know a reason yeah I think I think
the house needs to can't afford to buy
you out by refinancing then we should
sell the house and split the proceeds
and she goes and buy something honey can
I drop that up but she wants it so bad
that's why I know rocky knows when I
need the ground I have really doesn't
matter what she wants um I you would
have to seek an attorney's advice my my
guess is that what you've done is you've
formed a general partnership in Florida
law may be a little different okay but
most places it would just be called a
general partnership and you don't have
any partnership documents mean you have
no agreement no nothing in writing
regardless partnership you all did it on
a handshake and um and so you know what
would happen if you went before a judge
on the disillusionment of a general
partner
ship generally speaking the judge is
going to say sell the assets and
everybody take their part of the
partnership and go their way and so
probably I'll give you a very high
probability that if you saw an attorney
the attorney would say well we can take
her to court and make her salad right
and so I you know what my conversation
if you discovered that to be true by
visiting with an attorney I'd want to
know I want you I want you to know have
legal advice from somebody other than
Dave Ramsey because I'm not a lawyer
okay but but go get a you know they'll
spend a session with a lawyer and say if
she won't do this we can take her to
court in civil court and make her do it
and make her sell the property or you
know we certainly would agree to
refinancing and buy her buying out half
that's fine too but only but but if she
can't do that
then we're going to sell it and then
let's say the lawyer says that what Dave
told you is right okay
then you just go sit down have a cup of
coffee with her and go listen I'm not
trying to be hard to get along with but
it's a bad it's a bad idea chemistry
wise for some day you to be married and
be making payments to me as your old
boyfriend so that is not going to go
well in your future it's certainly not
something I want I don't want to open an
envelope and think about you every month
I just I don't want to and then you
can't pay one month and then I've got a
problem and we got to dig all this up
again we need the clean break here so if
you can refinance and buy me out I'll
even give you a deal okay and you know
less than half okay going to give you a
bargain just to just to being easy to
get along with but but if you can't do
that then we need to sell the house I'm
not going to sell the house well
actually I've already talked to an
attorney and you are going to sell the
house because we're going to go to court
and the judge is going to make a sell
the house to get rid of the partnership
I don't really don't want to go there so
let's try to do this the easy way in the
cheap way and that is either you buy me
out or let's put it up for sale right
and if she bought if she balks at that
point once you've put reasonable strong
guidelines on the boundaries of this
breakup of the
and you may have to take her to court to
force the sale of it I would do that for
I take payments in there dude I just you
really don't want to be calling me up in
five years and going hey my wife really
resents the fact that I get payments
from you know you want that conversation
man it's just yeah yeah and what this is
why people for those of you listening
that you don't buy a house or someone
that you aren't married to right here
because there's no rules and the only
rules are you know you're up in the air
here with note with a verbal agreement
on a general partnership and so some
judge has got to look at you and make a
decision and and that's going to cost
you three grand minimum in attorneys
fees and court costs to just go get a
simple ruling like that you know I'm
probably three times that but it's going
to cost you at least that and so you
guys would have been better off to not
buy the house together went back when
you did so anyway
hindsight's always 20/20 but there you
be man thank you for the call I hope
that helps you that's how I would step
through and I'd get the information from
an attorney confirmed that my suspicions
are correct then I would sit down in
person as painful as that is public
place cup of coffee at Starbucks or
whatever and have a gentle but very firm
conversation or either going to
refinance or we're going to sell because
you're not going to pay me payments this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh